euh Michel est avec nous il fa faire le
point sur les affaires et c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu des révélations incroyables
euh ce weekend notamment sur l'attentat
d'arace on vaar on va d'abord commencer
par ça après onevendra sur cette
histoire de ce sénateur qui a été placé
en garde à vue une histoire complètement
folle il a été il est accusé d'avoir
drogué une députée cette histoire il
faut Michel va nous la raconter et enfin
on évoquera ce drame ce jeune de 16 ans
qui a été tué par une dizaine de
personnes armé au couteau dans un
village dans la drô c'était hier euh
d'abord alors vraiment les incroyables
révélations sur le tueur d'aras euh
il paraît que lors de son interrogatoire
le lendemain son attaque mortel au
couteau qui a coûté la vie à Dominique
Bernard il nargit les policiers oui tout
à fait il a eu pendant ses 96 heures de
garde à vue une attitude de défiance en
permanence ou en quasi
permanence on le voit dire on l'entend
dire vous m'avez manqué non je
rigole il imaginait briser ses menottes
comme dans les films il dit ça serait
stylé quand
même tenu du crime qu'il avait
commis c'était quand même assez mal venu
ces 96 he de gardeavion ont été ponctué
de je vous laisse deviner des silences
aussi où je ne souhaite pas m'exprimer
ou encore il se mettait à faire une
prière coranique marmonner les yeux vers
le ciel après il explique qu'il voulait
aller au paradis donc parce que il
essayait donc de faire de bonnes
actions en étant un bon
musulman fidèle à sa religion qui est
l'Islam et il conclut en disant seul
Dieu décidera si mon acte en fait partie
alors ce qui est il y a un élément qui
est incroyable avant son passage à
l'acte et sur son passage à l'acte c'est
qu'il avait tout prévu tout écrit c'est
ça qui est alors il avait absolument
tout préparé tout minuté dans son sac à
dos il y avait quatre feuillets quatre
feuillets où tout son projet criminel
était marqué comme un scénario avec les
horaires les horaires de bus également
pour partir au cas où il aurait réussi à
partir il avait marqué aussi de les les
heures des sonneries du lycée quand il y
a la récréation et quand les cours
reprennent il avait également projeté
d'acheter un téléphone portable il y a
même le tarif de ce téléphone 129 €
euh voilà en gros il avait tout préparé
et ce probablement depuis des semaines
peut-être même des mois il avait préparé
son geste criminel il a il a même envoyé
la Une de Marianne décapité sur un
compte télégram oui alors il a envoyé
deux euh deux deux deux messages alors
on n pas les les destinataires hein ça
sera a priori des des des musulmans
russes ils ont pas été identifiés pour
l'instant en tout cas envoyé quand même
des vidéos de de
décapitations d'imagees de photos une
qui représente Charlie Hebdo et l'autre
autre qui
représente Marianne décapitée
effectivement alors lors de son attaque
il blesse au thorax david v un prof de
PS qu' prend en chasse dans la cour de
récréation et leur échange à ce
moment-là a été révélé je l'interp je
l'interpelle immédiatement lui disant
Mohamed mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que tu fais sans qu'il me
donne de réponse j'étais obsédé par son
regard noir et froid il a commencé à
parler en ces termes qui te donne l'air
que tu respires qui est le seul Dieu je
lui ai posé la question qu'est-ce que tu
veux Mohamed que je me convertisse je
lui ai parlé de mes enfants et cetera
tout à fait et il faut préciser que
David l'avait eu comme ce ce ce
professeur l'avait eu comme élève en 6e
et en 4e donc il le connaissait très
bien et quand il le voit arriver avec
ses yeux de fou il a un moment de
silération et ensuite quand il comprend
qu'il est venu pour en découdre et et
pour commettre lesffit qu'il a commis il
a essayé de de d'intervenir il a été
blessé euh il a pris trois coups de
couteau un au coup un au thorax et un
dans le dos alors vous allez voir il y a
des révélations incroyables notamment
dans Le Parisien on va revenir sur cette
affaire cette deuxième affaire un
sénateur accusé d'avoir drogué une
députée pour abuser d'elle que s'est-il
passé ça cette histoire elle est
incroyable j'y croyais pas alors c'est
complètement fou euh c'est un un député
de 66 ans non un sénateur pardon de 66
ans qui est sénateur d'Ur pas un député
non c'est un sénateur sénateur centred
droit Joël guerriot il est âgé de 66 ans
il en est à son 3e mandat il est en
Loire Atlantique et euh mardi dernier il
avait invité une députée là pour le coup
Sandrine josau qui a 45 ans qui est
député du MoDem il avait invité à dîner
à son domicile et début de la soirée
c'était plutôt bien passé
et le le sénateur lui offre une coupe de
champagne qu'elle accepte je précise
qu'ils se connaissent depuis 10 ans
qu'ils sont amis et qu'ils ont une
relation assez suivie mais pas une
relation enfin il se passe rien au
niveau sentimental entre ces deux-là je
précise également que Joel guerot est
marié et père de CIN enfants d'accord et
donc il l'invite à dîner il lui offre
une coupe de champagne et un quart
d'heure 20 minutes après avoir bu cette
coupe de
champagne cette jeune femme Sandrine
joso se sent pas bien elle a elle se
elle se met à transpirer elle a des
sueurs son cœur se met à battre beaucoup
plus vite une sorte de
taticardie et là elle comprend euh
qu'elle a été droguée et elle se
souvient même avoir vu euh son ami enfin
son exami maintenant Joël guerot euh
sortir un d'un tiroir de la cuisine un
petit sachet en plastique transparent et
avait un produit blanc à l'intérieur
donc elle l'a pas vu mettre dans le
verre mais en tout cas elle a fait le
rapprochement entre ce ce mouvement et
l'état dans lequel elle se trouve et là
elle a fait preuve d'un sang frroid
incroyable il faut dire que que le
domicile de de ce sénateur est assez
proche de l'Assemblée nationale elle
part en très mauvais état à l'Assemblée
nationale elle demande du secours à des
collègues qui étaient encore sur place
qui compte tenu de son état ont prévenu
les secours le SAMU est arrivé elle a
été hospitalisé on a fait des analyses
de sang d'urine et on s'aperçoit qu'elle
avait de l'extasie dans dans le corps
Chud et à partir de là elle a évidemment
déposé plainte auprès des services de
police c'est le 3è district de police
on a on a trouvé les analyses elle était
testé positive à plusieurs drogues
amphétamine opiacé cannabis cocaïne
métadone
m c'est c'est le sénateur qui est ceux
qui contestent lui alors lui lui frère
cocaï et d'ailleurs je précise que
lorsqu'il a été interpellé le
surlendemain il y a eu une perquisition
évidemment faite à son domicile on a
retouvéas alors déf il s'est défendu sa
défense est lunaire oui alors abent lire
alors je précise juste cy que la députée
elle se méfie un petit peu parce qu'au
départ il l'invite pour fêter les
sénatoriales voilà et donc elle pense
que c'est au restaurant puis après il
dit non c'est chez moi elle pense qu'il
y a d'autres gens elle arrive elle est
toute seule donc elle se méfie et après
c'est pour ça que très vite elle se dit
il m'a fait ingérer quelque chose ça
défense lui c'est incroyable alors son
avocat dit oui ce jour-là il était pas
bien son chat est mort son chat qu'il
adorait est mort il était pas bien un de
ses amis son meilleur ami lui annonce
qu'il est très malade donc il va pas
bien et puis il a une petite coupe de
champagne il se dit je vais prendre un
verre de champagne et on lui a donné un
produit dit son avocat on lui a donné un
produit un neuf horizant il y a quelques
temps il met dans la coupe de champagne
c'est une coupe colorée il met dans la
coupe de champagne puis finalement il
boit pas la coupe il sort mais il laisse
le produit dans une coupe de champagne
et quand la députée arrive il sert le
champagne dans la coupe ne se souvenant
pas qu'il y a le produit à l'intérieur
c'est totalement délirant alors alors
mais il il dit il plaide l'erreur de
manipulation voulu lui faire ingérer ça
je pensais que c'était un uf horizon que
j'ai mis dans la coupe et puis je l'ai
oublié il y a rien de conscient chez moi
voilà pour lui faire inérer le ver était
mal essuyé de la veille c'est pour ça
qu'il restait des produits sur le
ver ça paraît plus que léger ça par plus
queg d'accord alors il y a Gérard Larché
qui demande sa démission le président du
Sénat qu'est-ce qui va passer se mett en
retrait il lui a demandé de se mettre en
retra m en retra m en retrait va se
mettre donc là il y a la
son ok très bien donc là ser son patron
ouais
son pr il est pr d' pH
Philipp était venu le soutenir lors des
sénatorial exactement on va passer à
cette trè histoire dramatique un jeune
de 16 ans tué lors d'une fête de village
euh c'est un truc de fou ça c'est Thomas
qui a été tué poignardé dans une bagarre
les fesses sont déroulées dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche une expédition
punitive c'est dans un petit village de
la PR près de Valence dans la Drome à
Crépol une grande un grand bal un grand
bal dans ce petit village de campagne
tous les tous les les jeunes et un peu
moins jeunes d'ailleurs viennent
s'amuser il y avait longtemps qu'ils
avaient pas organisé un bal l'ambiance
était plutôt festive tout se passait
bien jusqu'à 2h 2h10 du matin au moment
où le bal touche à sa fin il y a une une
arrivée massive d'une dizaine de de de
personnes qui très vite ont voulu
rentrer à l'intérieur de la de la salle
de de bal refoulé par le videur parce
que d'une part parce que c'était fermé
d'autre part parce que c'était une
soirée
privée une bagarre éclate entre le
videur et ces jeunes qui sont arrivé ça
a dégénéré parce que d'autres se sont
emmêlés pour défendre le videur ils ont
sorti des couteaux il y a une bagare
général il plantait un témoin dit il
plantait à
l'aveugle il tapait des coups de couteau
absolument partout le vier a eu les
doigts sectionnés coupés
sectionnés et malheureusement dans cette
histoire un jeune Thomas 16 ans a été
mortellement touché par des coups de
couteau alors c'est un déflement
déferlement déferlement de violence il a
même un témoin qui dit c'était tellement
violent qu'au début j'ai cru un attentat
terroriste tellement c'était violent
elle a vu les les poignards
effectivement il y avait des très
longues lames j'ai j'ai vu qu'il y avait
une lame de 25 cm donc c'est des des des
vraiment des couteaux pour tuer quoi ils
sont venus pour tuer il y a deux blessés
graves et en tout il y a eu six autres
personnes blessées et 17 personnes
touchées et s le vigile avait pas été là
parce que il s'interpose ça aurait pu
être encore beaucoup plus sanglant comme
bilan c'est déjà dramatique justement
qu'est-ce qu'on sait des agresseurs bah
pour le moment il y a pas énormément de
choses on se dit que peut-être ils ont
été refoulés une première fois qu'il
sont arrivés ensuite on a parlé aussi
d'un quartier sensible quartier la
monnaie de roman suriser qui est distant
de quelques kilomètres voilà pour le
moment est-ce que c'est une expédition
punitive planifiée est-ce que c'est une
vengeance après avoir été refoulé de la
soirée voilà pour le moment à l'heure où
on parle là qu'il se soit présenté en
tout début de soirée ils ont été déjà V
à ce momentl avec des lames de 25 cm et
c'est à ce moment-l qu'on les a refoulé
et comme il l'aurait très très mal pris
ils se sont dit on va revenir en fin de
soirée et on le fera à l'extérieur et
c'est là qu'ils ont attaqué les jeunes
qui une expédition punitive parle d'une
expédition punitive exactement il y a
Hugo un autre jeune homme qui est à la
soirée et connaissance de Thomas qui a
malheureusement vu tout ce qui s'est
passé il a dit Hugo j'étais vers
l'entrée j'ai vu Thomas se faire planter
un couteau dans le cœur et dans la gorge
un hélico là mais il y est passé
malheureusement je suis choqué c'était
un collègue à moi on était au collège
ensemble je l'ai vu mourir il y a eu une
bataille entre les agresseurs et ceux
qui ont eu le courage de leur faire face
oui parce que les les autres à
l'intérieur av avaient pas de couteau
avent pas d'armes ils avaient juste
leurs bras et leur et leur pieds pour se
défendre contre une horde sauvage d'une
bonne dizaine d'individus armé de
couteau qui étit arrivé comme on vient
de le dire une première fois puis une
deuxième fois pour régler régler leur
compte alors il y a un il y a un Chalon
où vivait Thomas les habitants sont sous
le choc comme Aline j'ai failli m
fondrer ce matin je suis totalement
bouleversé c'est inexplicable je le
connaissais très bien ses parents sont
des gens formidables il n'y avait pas
plus gentil et poli que Thomas toujours
à traverser la rue pour vous dire
bonjour souriant c'est un acte gratuit
il n'y a pas de mot et c'est vrai que
c'est un acte gratuit absolument il
avait 16 ans céit un rugby man tout le
monde l'adore ainsi que sa famille
devant le lycée ce matin c'était l'état
de choc absolu donc voilà c'est on le
voit derrière vous là c'est une mort
tragique pour une expédition punitive
c'est dramatique dramatique ça veut dire
quoi expédition punitive en fait ça veut
dire donc on va dans une soirée on
rentre pas dans la soirée on revient
avec et on se dit qu'on revient avec des
copains et voilà est renu avec des
copains par qu'il pas rentré dans la
soiréeu avec des Coutau ils ont voulu se
venger ê rentré j'attends l'enquête
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais
j'attends l'enquête on attend savoir
parce que ça me paraît juste
complètement aberrant quoi c'est c'est
même pas l'ensauvagement de la société
là c'est quand même c'est des barbares
en fait on rentre pas dans une soirée on
arrive avec des les poignard les gens
c'est juste
incroyableors et c'est très bizarre
c'est oui je précise que tout se passait
bien c'était bon enfant à l'intérieur
c'est vraiment des des gens du du coin
qui se connaissent et qui
s'amusaient sur un bal après après le
covid enfin il y avait tout un tas de
d'événements qui n'avaient pas permis de
réorganiser de bal depuis plusieurs
années donc c'était le premier mal
depuis un petit moment et tout le monde
était content pour l'instant l'enquête
il interp personne non non non au moment
où ça le drame c'est il ninterpelle
personne et là il tente de remonter
petit à petit de travailler sur les
différentes pistes mais c'est pas si
facile et c'est vrai qu'il y avait 350
jeunes dans la salle des fêtes donc ils
sont entrés là ouais c'est ça et et et
ils sont revenus en voiture à deux
bandes et puis ils ont tapé tout ce qu'
pouvait c'est un tout petit village de
530 habitants donc c'est sidérant en
milieu rural comme ça c'est incroyable
je pense que l'enquête sera
effectivement compliquée mais je pense
qu'ils y arriveront parce que d'abord
ils ont été vus par plein de par plein
de
gens des phot ville ROM sur exactement
roman suriser c'est pas non plus c'est
pas Chicago hein c'est sûr c'est sûr que
c'est ils vont ils vont être retrouvés
très très vite on espère en tout cas on
pense fort à la famille de de ce jeun h